- We are announcing our plan
to stay ahead of this virus
by being prepared to offer
COVID-19 booster shots
to fully vaccinated
adults 18 years and older.
They would be eligible
for their booster shot
eight months after
receiving their second dose
of the Pfizer or Moderna mRNA vaccines.
We plan to start this program
the week of September 20th, 2021.
- [Narrator] The Biden
administration booster announcement
comes amid reports of fully
vaccinated people getting COVID,
cases known as breakthrough infections.
This includes a Wall
Street Journal analysis
that found the Delta
variant is breaking through
vaccine protection at a higher
rate than other strains.
- I wanna be very clear.
This plan is pending the FDA conducting
an independent evaluation of
the safety and effectiveness
of a third dose of the Pfizer
and Moderna mRNA vaccines
and the CDC's advisory committee
on immunization practices
issuing booster dose recommendations
based on a thorough
review of the evidence.
- [Narrator] Here's why
a third-dose booster shot
of mRNA vaccines is now recommended
for fully vaccinated people.
(bell dinging)
Data suggests that while
vaccines are still shown
to be highly effective,
as antibodies begin to dwindle naturally,
the protection vaccines
offer it can wane over time.
The mRNA boosters that
the Biden administration
is recommending could have a big impact.
Studies show that they
generate higher levels
of neutralizing antibodies
than just two doses alone.
Neutralizing antibodies are
the ones primarily responsible
for stopping the virus
from entering cells.
- Antibodies are seen as providing
some of that initial
protection against the virus,
potentially stopping
infection from happening
and from the virus from spreading.
The reason why we are seeing
vaccines still hold up
and be effective at
preventing hospitalization
or severe disease or death
is because of other parts
of the immune system,
what's known as the
adaptive immune system,
such as T cells or memory B cells.
T cells actually identify, seek out,
and destroy the infected cells.
- [Narrator] The mRNA vaccine
makers have released data
showing that antibody
levels have increased
following booster shots,
and Pfizer and partner
BioNTech are planning
to seek clearance from the
FDA for a COVID-19 booster
for the general population.
The company said they sent the FDA results
from a small early stage studies
showing a third dose of
vaccines generated higher levels
of neutralizing antibodies
against the original virus,
as well as the Beta and Delta variants.
The third dose appeared
safe in the trial as well.
The Biden administration is
recommending that booster shots
for the general public be
taken about eight months
after the second dose of mRNA vaccines.
But for some who are immunocompromised
and don't have a strong immune response
to the standard two-course
vaccine regimen,
booster shots could be needed even sooner.
The current guidance in
the CDC is that those
who are moderately to
severely immunocompromised
should take a third
dose of an mRNA vaccine
at least 28 days after the second shot.
- Immunocompromised people
is a very broad term
that includes people who
are transplant patients,
so if you have a kidney transplant.
It can include some cancer patients.
Basically individuals whose immune systems
don't necessarily respond
like the general populations.
- [Narrator] Some of those
who fall into this category
should be able to walk
into certain clinics
to get a booster shot now,
but for the general population,
boosters have not yet
been approved by the FDA,
which gives final approval on vaccines.
Pfizer is the furthest along
in the regulatory approval process,
but Moderna, which also produces
a two-dose mRNA vaccine,
said it plans to ask regulators next month
to authorize booster shots as well.
- The plan ensures that people
who were fully vaccinated
earliest in the vaccination rollout
will be eligible for a booster first.
This includes our most
vulnerable populations,
like our healthcare providers,
nursing home residents,
and other seniors.
- [Narrator] Johnson &
Johnson does not make
an mRNA vaccine,
which means the current
booster guidelines won't apply.
- For people who received the
Johnson & Johnson vaccine,
we anticipate vaccine boosters
will likely be needed.
The J & J vaccine was not
administered in the U.S.
until March of 2021,
and we expect more data on
J & J in the coming weeks.
- [Narrator] The company's
expected to release data
about the efficacy of two doses
of its single-shot vaccine
later this month.
The White House has
said that it is prepared
with enough extra vaccine orders
if the FDA approves the booster.
- That is why we ordered the
number of doses we did order
several months ago because
we are like boy scouts
and girl scouts and
always wanna be prepared.
(bell dinging)